A quick warning-- there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website-- thisamericanlife.org. Darwin's nine. And he's a kid who-- I don't know-- people just give him stuff. When he met my co-worker, Aviva, he was playing with a soccer ball somebody gave him, eating a taco somebody else gave him. And Darwin's mom was explaining all this.
一个简短的警告——今天这期节目中包含未经消音的脏话。如果你更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。达尔文九岁。他是个孩子——我不知道该怎么说——人们就是会给他东西。当他见到我的同事阿维娃时，他正在玩别人送给他的足球，吃着别人给他的塔可。达尔文的妈妈当时正在解释这一切。
Comemos más porque nos traigan.
我们吃得更多是因为他们给我们带吃的。
Can you just describe what just happened?
你能描述一下刚刚发生了什么吗？
No tengo ni idea
我不知道。
I have no idea, she says.
她说，我不知道。
A man, as you were talking about people just giving him things, walked by and gave you-- how much did he give you? Diez?
在你谈论人们给他东西的时候，有个男人走过来给了你——他给了你多少？十块？
Diez.
十块。
Wow.
哇。
Diez. Diez Pesos.
十块。十比索。
10 pesos.
10比索。
Y por que te dio eso?
他为什么要给你钱？
Why'd he give you that? Aviva asks him. Darwin gives a little shrug like, eh, what can I say?
阿维娃问他为什么要给他钱。达尔文耸了耸肩，好像在说，我能说什么呢？
Porque pensaba que yo estaba pidiendo una moneda.
因为他以为我在乞讨硬币。
Because he thought I was asking for a coin. His mom says, he was just sitting there eating.
她说，因为他以为我在讨钱。他当时只是坐在那里吃东西。
You're like king of the camp.
你简直就是这个营地的国王。
Que si, soy el rey del campamento!
没错，我是营地的国王！
Yes, I am the king of the camp, he says. As Aviva sits there with Darwin's mom, Elizabeth, he runs off for 15, 20 minutes at a time. And then returns with cash.
他说，没错，我是营地的国王。当阿维娃和达尔文的妈妈伊丽莎白坐在一起时，他每次都会跑开15到20分钟，然后带着现金回来。
Ay Dios mio, santo Dios. Cinco dolares.
天哪，圣母啊。五美元。
Cinco!  Dolar!
五美元！
$5. She hugs him.
5美元。她拥抱了他。
Ay, tan lindo.  Muchachito.
哎，真可爱。小家伙。
Darwin runs to their tent to pull out all the money he's saved and show Aviva-- $279, a huge wad of cash, which for context, they're living in a makeshift tent camp in Matamoros, Mexico, right over the border from Brownsville, Texas. And, I mean, immediately on the other side-- nestled against the US, and the Rio Grande, and the customs office. You can see the big red arches of the border station it's so close.
达尔文跑到他们的帐篷里，拿出他存的所有钱给阿维娃看——279美元，一大叠现金。说明一下背景，他们住在墨西哥马塔莫罗斯的一个临时帐篷营地里，就在德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的边境对面。我的意思是，就在那边——紧挨着美国、格兰德河和海关办公室。你可以看到边境站巨大的红色拱门，离得非常近。
Over 2,500 people living here, hoping to get asylum in the US. Darwin and his mom came here from Honduras. 279 bucks here is huge.
有超过2500人住在这里，希望在美国获得庇护。达尔文和他的妈妈是从洪都拉斯来到这里的。在这里，279美元是一笔巨款。
Most people, even the migrants who came with a little money saved, have been here so long, they've spent it all. Our family sends us money, his mom says. Lots of families do that. But he brings in so much more than they send.
大多数人，即使是带了一些积蓄来的移民，也在这里待了太久，钱已经花光了。他妈妈说，我们家给我们寄钱。很多家庭都这样做。但他挣的比寄来的多得多。
Es inteligentísimo.
他非常聪明。
Aviva then follows Darwin as he walks from the tents to the long line of cars that's waiting at the border to cross into the United States. He's a happy-looking kid with neatly cut hair and a big smile. Really cute.
阿维娃随后跟着达尔文，他从帐篷走到边境排队等待进入美国的车队。他看起来是个快乐的孩子，头发修剪得很整齐，脸上挂着灿烂的笑容。真的很可爱。
Darwin gives a fist bump to the fruit stand guy. Claps the man selling corn on the back to say hello. Nods to the half-dozen other vendors working the line. Remember, he's nine.
达尔文和卖水果的人击掌。拍拍卖玉米男人的后背打招呼。向沿线工作的其他六个小贩点头。记住，他才九岁。
When we asked one woman in the camp about him, she was like, oh, El Terremoto-- The Earthquake. He holds a finger in the air, asking for one coin.
当我们问营地里的一位妇女关于他的事时，她说，哦，地震——那个“地震”。他举起一根手指，讨要一枚硬币。
He says that's his move-- ask for a coin, and then hopefully they'll give you more than a coin. And, in fact, a car with three women waves him over. And the woman in the passenger seat rolls down her window and hands him a dollar.
他说这就是他的绝招——先要一枚硬币，然后希望他们给的会比一枚硬币多。事实上，一辆载着三名妇女的车向他招手。副驾驶座上的妇女摇下车窗，递给他一美元。
Gracias. Que los bendiga!
谢谢。愿主保佑你们！
Thanks. Bless you. Are you Cuban? He asks her.
谢谢。愿主保佑你们。你是古巴人吗？他问她。
Es Cubana?
你是古巴人吗？
He says, I knew it-- from your accent. And she's like, right. You thought I was from Cuba. And they laugh. The woman asks his name, and he tells her.
他说，我就知道——从你的口音听出来的。她说，没错。你以为我是古巴人。他们笑了。那名妇女问他的名字，他告诉了她。
She says she likes his hair. I like your hair, he says. He reaches out to stroke her hair. It's straight and blond. I like your hair because it's pretty, he says. And she laughs and claps her hands. Look at what a flirt he ended up being.
她说她喜欢他的头发。他说，我也喜欢你的头发。他伸出手去抚摸她的头发。是直的金发。他说，我喜欢你的头发，因为很漂亮。她笑了，拍了拍手。你看这个小伙子多会调情。
Mira coqueto salió este. Ay Dios mío, tu tienes novia?
瞧这个小家伙多会撩人。天哪，你有女朋友吗？
Oh, my god. You have a girlfriend?
天哪。你有女朋友吗？
Usted es!  Usted es!
是你！是你！
You, you.
你，是你。
Bye, Darwin!
再见，达尔文！
Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。
Darwin runs to his mom, who's watching all this, and gives her the dollar. Both of them, and the thousands of other people camped here at the border-- to be clear, they're trying to follow the rules and enter the United States through a border station and formally apply for asylum. It used to be, you'd show up. If you passed a basic interview-- which most people did-- you'd wait in the US for your day in court.
达尔文跑向一直在看这一切的妈妈，把钱交给了她。他们和成千上万住在边境的其他人——明确地说，他们正试图遵守规定，通过边境站正式申请庇护。过去，你只要出现，如果通过了基本的面试——大多数人都通过了——你就可以在美国等待开庭。
But now it's all different. Under the Trump administration's Remain in Mexico policy, you get turned back to wait in Mexico. This policy is still pretty new. It really kicked in full force this summer, but it's a profound change with massive consequences.
但现在完全不同了。在特朗普政府的“留在墨西哥”政策下，你会被赶回墨西哥等待。这项政策还是很新的。它在今年夏天才全面生效，但这是一个深刻的变化，后果极其严重。
One of them? The size of this camp, which didn't exist before President Trump, and which grows in size every day. And all across Mexico, in cities just on the other side of the border, there are now tens of thousands of people-- according to the Department of Homeland Security-- stranded under this policy, in shelters, on the streets, and in encampments like this one, sent by our government without much of a plan for where or how they'd live once they got to Mexico.
后果之一？这个营地的规模，在特朗普总统上台前并不存在，而且每天都在扩大。据国土安全部称，在墨西哥整个边境对面的城市里，现在有成千上万的人——根据这项政策滞留，在收容所、街头和像这样的营地里。我们的政府把他们送过来，但对他们到了墨西哥之后如何生存、住在哪里几乎没有任何计划。
This camp, for instance, is totally improvised-- long rows of scruffy blue and white and gray tents, over 700 of them, donated by do-gooder groups and churches in America. These are Coleman tents meant for weekend camping, not designed for rain and direct sun and cold for months at a time.
比如这个营地，完全是临时的——一排排破旧的蓝色、白色和灰色帐篷，超过700个，由美国的慈善团体和教会捐赠。这些是科尔曼牌的帐篷，适合周末露营，不是为长期经受雨淋、暴晒和寒冷而设计的。
There's no regular water supply here. Volunteer groups from over the border in Brownsville haul in over 3,000 bottles of water each day, and these are just the little 16-ounce bottles like you would buy with your lunch at a fast food place. There's no proper sanitation, just five toilets for 2,500 people-- yellow Porta Potties which get precisely as gross as you would imagine.
这里没有常规的供水。来自布朗斯维尔边境对面的志愿者团体每天运来超过3000瓶水，这些只是你在快餐店吃午餐时会买的那种16盎司的小瓶水。这里没有合适的卫生设施，2500人共用五个厕所——黄色的移动厕所，其肮脏程度你可以想象。
One of the fathers here, Elwin David Baquis told me that when his eight-year-old daughter needs the bathroom--
这里的一位父亲埃尔文·大卫·巴奎斯告诉我，当他八岁的女儿需要上厕所时——
No, pues si cuando tengo dinero le busco otro baño.
不，如果有钱的话，我会带她去找别的厕所。
Well, you know, if I have some money, then I'll look and see if I can find her another bathroom to use, but if there isn't any, then I'll take her out into the woods-- into the mountain, so that she can, you know, use the bathroom, do her business, and then we'll go down to the river to wash up.
嗯，你知道，如果我有钱，我会四处寻找，看能不能帮她找到另一个厕所用。但如果没有，我就带她去树林里——去山里，让她，你知道，去上个厕所，解决一下，然后我们再下到河边去洗一洗。
Para tantas personas. No tienen ni cinco horas cuando ya están repletos.
为了这么多的人。不到五个小时就全满了。
And honestly, with the amount of people using them, in five hours, they'll be totally full. And people still keep on going to use them, especially women, because as you can imagine, you know, like, there's a bunch of men out there in the woods that are using the bathroom, and they don't want to be surrounded by that.
说实话，用的人太多了，不到五个小时，它们就会完全满溢。但人们还是不得不继续使用，尤其是女性，因为你可以想象，树林里有一群男人在方便，她们不想被那样包围。
There's a nurse at the camp named Helen Perry who runs a very small relief group with a very grand-sounding name-- Global Response Management. With some volunteers, she started a medical tent in the camp, modeled after the battalion aid stations that she learned to set up back when she was in the army. Anyway, I mentioned all of this to Helen-- that this father and daughter were going up in the woods. And she was like, oh yeah, knew that.
营地里有一位名叫海伦·佩里的护士，她经营着一个名字听起来很宏大的小型救援组织——全球响应管理。她和一些志愿者在营地里建立了一个医疗帐篷，仿照她参军时学会建立的营级援助站。无论如何，我把这一切告诉了海伦——那对父女要去树林里解决。她说，哦，我知道。
Yeah. And then when it rains, all that rainwater washes down there, or it washes into the hard spaces in the camp and they get, you know, infectious diarrhea.
是啊。然后下雨时，所有的雨水都会冲刷到那里，或者冲刷进营地的硬地空间，他们就会感染腹泻。
Are you seeing a lot of infectious diarrhea?
你们看到了很多感染性腹泻病例吗？
Yes. Most everyone here has some form of GI something or other-- you know, different types of tapeworms and ringworms. And the problem is is that you treat it, and then they come right back out and they get it again.
是的。这里几乎每个人都有某种形式的胃肠道问题——你知道，各种各样的绦虫和蛔虫。问题是，你治好了，他们又走出去，结果又感染了。
I actually met Elwin because he was Helen's first patient of the day. He and his daughter both had pinkeye from bathing in the Rio Grande, which is not clean. Helen's trying to organize a fix for that.
我实际上是遇到埃尔文的，因为他是海伦当天的第一个病人。他和他的女儿因为在格兰德河里洗澡都得了红眼病，那河水很不干净。海伦正试图组织解决这个问题。
So this is actually one of areas that we're talking about bringing in a water purification system. So the Rio Grande is, like, right down there. Hola.
这就是我们谈论要引入净水系统的区域之一。格兰德河就在那里。你好。
Hola.
你好。
And so what we want to do is put in a water purification system right over here, run a hose out into the water. It'll suck up the water, purify it, and they'll have their own water source.
所以我们想做的是在这里安装一个净水系统，把软管接到水里。它会吸入水，净化它，这样他们就有自己的水源了。
And you're the one organizing this?
你是组织者？
Yeah.
是的。
Not a government?
不是政府吗？
No, no.
不，不是。
Not the UN?
不是联合国？
Nope.
不是。
Just you, a person.
就你，一个人。
I've never-- people are like, have you done water? And I'm like, no, but like, I'll Google it.
我以前从来没——人们问我，你处理过水吗？我说，没有，但我会去谷歌查一下。
I have to say, this is the thing that hit me hardest in Matamoros. You have thousands of people stuck there, right on our border, two big governments-- the United States and Mexico-- one of them, of course, a lot richer than the other, and nobody's looking after these people with food and water and shelter, except a bunch volunteers who raised their hands and said, we cannot ignore this.
我必须说，这是在马塔莫罗斯让我最受冲击的事。成千上万的人被困在那里，就在我们的边境上。两个大政府——美国和墨西哥——其中一个当然比另一个富裕得多，但除了几个自告奋勇说“我们不能无视这一切”的志愿者外，没有人照顾这些人的食物、水和住所。
Buenas tardes. Hoy día tenemos voluntarios que vienen de Indiana.
下午好。今天我们有来自印第安纳州的志愿者。
Good afternoon. Today we have volunteers from Indiana.
Y de Indianapolis,
还有印第安纳波利斯。
From Indianapolis.
来自印第安纳波利斯。
Muy lejos!
太远了！
Really far.
真的太远了！
A cocinar para ustedes.
来为你们做饭。
To cook for you.
Porque todos somos hermanos, verdad.
因为我们都是兄弟，对吧。
Because we're all brothers, right?
So les vamos a decir gracias. Un aplauso para nuestros voluntarios.
所以我们要说声谢谢。为我们的志愿者鼓掌。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
So let's say thanks with a round of applause. Eight very nice ladies from Indiana in fluorescent green t-shirts start serving food out of aluminum foil trays, food for 1,000 people. It cost $1,900, which they raised back home in 20 dollar donations. They also paid for their own flights and everything.
让我们用掌声表示感谢。八位来自印第安纳州的非常友善的女士穿着荧光绿色T恤，开始用铝箔盘分发食物，为1000人提供食物。成本是1900美元，这是她们在家乡通过20美元的捐款筹集的。她们还自费支付了机票和一切费用。
An impressively competent group that calls itself Team Brownsville, started by a bunch of teachers, all volunteer, has organized it so a different bunch of people shows up five nights a week with food. They also pay for a Matamoros restaurant to deliver hundreds of breakfasts each day. The food today is fresh, but very north of the border, and very plain-- slices of ham and cheese on white bread, tangerines, grapes, baby carrots. Everybody we ask about the food, though, is polite enough to say how great it is.
一个自称为“布朗斯维尔团队”的非常称职的组织，由一群老师发起，全都是志愿者。他们组织了每周五个晚上有不同的人来送食物。他们还花钱让马塔莫罗斯的一家餐馆每天运送数百份早餐。今天的食物很新鲜，但在边境以北是非常普通的——白面包上放火腿和奶酪片、橘子、葡萄、婴儿胡萝卜。不过，我们问的所有人对于食物都客气地表示非常棒。
Pues rica.
很可口。
Si?
是吗？
Todos los dias
每天都是。
It's tasty, this guy tells Aviva.
这个人告诉阿维娃，很可口。
La comida es rica? Bien rica. Si.
食物好吃吗？非常好吃。是的。
It's tasty, right? He says to the woman next to him. Oh sure, very tasty, she says. As soon as Aviva walks away, the interpreter who was with us for the day, Gabby Muñoz, overhears what happens next.
好吃吗，对吧？他对旁边的妇女说。哦，当然，非常可口，她说。阿维娃一走开，当天陪同我们的翻译加比·穆尼奥斯就无意中听到了接下来发生的事情。
Oh yeah, then afterwards, like, her friend, or like, the guy or the person's friend was like, what did she ask you? And he's like, well, she asked me how good the food was and I said it was good, but what the fuck else was I supposed to say? [LAUGHS]
哦，是的，在那之后，她的朋友或者那个人的朋友问她：她问了你什么？他说：嗯，她问我食物怎么样，我说很好，但我还能说什么呢？[笑声]
Generally, they try to get the volunteers out of the camp by nightfall, because Matamoros isn't safe. The cartels are here. The city has one of the highest kidnapping rates in Mexico, according to the US State Department. Its web page about Matamoros says, murder, carjacking, and sexual assault are common. Gang gun battles are widespread. Anybody here is at high risk.
通常，他们尽量在天黑前让志愿者离开营地，因为马塔莫罗斯不安全。贩毒集团在这里。据美国国务院称，该市是墨西哥绑架率最高的城市之一。关于马塔莫罗斯的网页称，谋杀、劫车和性侵犯很常见。帮派枪战很普遍。任何在这里的人都面临高风险。
Not far from where they serve the food, like, just 20 feet or so from the actual border station, a woman named Jenny and her husband and her daughter set up their tent. I asked her if she chose that spot because it seemed like the safest, closes into the border like that.
在离他们发食物的地方不远，离实际边境站只有20英尺左右的地方，一个叫珍妮的女人和她的丈夫及女儿搭建了帐篷。我问她是否选择这个位置，因为看起来最安全，离边境最近。
Si, es más seguro...
是的，更安全……
She said yes, and explained that she and her husband and daughter had been kidnapped in the last city they were in.
她说是的，并解释说她和丈夫及女儿在他们待过的上一个城市被绑架了。
Fue en Reynosa. Quince días estuvimos secuestrados.
是在雷诺萨。我们被绑架了15天。
So it was in Reynosa, and we were kidnapped for 15 days.
所以是在雷诺萨，我们被绑架了15天。
She starts to tell the story of her family and the cartel, and the house they were held in, but as she does, a man quietly approaches and just kind of hovers nearby, listening. And she says, atras, atras, atras-- look behind you-- and covers her face.
她开始讲述她家庭和贩毒集团的故事，以及他们被关押的房子。但当她讲时，一个男人悄悄靠近，就在附近徘徊，听着。她说，后面，后面，后面——看你后面——并捂住了脸。
Atrás atrás atrás. Están viendo. Atrás. No hay que hablar de eso. Están atrás.
后面后面后面。他们在看。后面。不能谈论那个。他们在后面。
You can't talk about this. He's behind.
你不能谈论这个。他在后面。
Peligroso.
危险。
We switch the subject. He goes away. A journalist who's in this camp a lot confirmed that he was a cartel guy. How much violence there is against people in the camp is not clear.
我们换了个话题。他走开了。一位经常在这个营地的记者证实那是贩毒集团的人。营地里针对人们的暴力程度尚不清楚。
The nurse, Helen Perry, has heard about people being kidnapped from the camp, but that's hard to confirm. And she told me this story.
护士海伦·佩里听说过有人从营地被绑架，但这很难证实。她告诉我这样一个故事。
When I first showed up in the camp, a woman came up to me and asked me if we would be bringing in condoms, because when she got sexually assaulted again she wanted to be able to ask her attacker to wear a condom so she wouldn't get pregnant.
当我第一次出现在营地时，一个女人走过来问我是否会带避孕套，因为当她再次被性侵时，她想让袭击者戴上避孕套，这样她就不会怀孕。
In her relief work, Helen's been to lots of places where migrants and refugees are stranded like this. But the security issues here-- the lack a predictable food and water and sanitation, five toilets where there should be 125, no proper tents for people--
在她的救援工作中，海伦去过很多移民和难民像这样滞留的地方。但这里的安全问题——缺乏可预见的食物、水和卫生设施，本应有125个厕所却只有5个，没有合适的帐篷——
When I first saw it, I was literally just dumbfounded, because I've seen refugee situations like this. I've been to Bangladesh. I've seen Cox's Bazar. I've been to Iraq. I've seen the IDP camps. I've seen the refugee camps from Syria.
当我第一次看到时，我真的惊呆了，因为我见过这样的难民情况。我去过孟加拉国。我见过科克斯巴扎尔。我去过伊拉克。我见过国内流离失所者营地。我见过叙利亚的难民营。
I'd say this was the worst. Yeah, I would definitely say that this is the worst, if at a bare minimum for a lack of humanitarian accountability for what's happening to these people.
我会说这是最糟糕的。是的，我肯定会说这是最糟糕的，如果仅从这些人所遭遇的人道主义问责缺失这一点来说。
You mean that nobody's keeping account of who's here and who isn't, who goes in and who goes out?
你是说没有人统计谁在这里，谁不在，谁进谁出？
Who goes in, who goes out, who goes missing.
谁进来，谁出去，谁失踪了。
At a proper refugee camp, she says, like a United Nations camp, they'd have that-- a big, tall fence, somebody keeping track of who comes in and out. When we asked Mexican officials about conditions in this camp, they said they aren't helping the 2,500 people here because they don't want a permanent tent city in the spot. They want people to move to government shelters.
她说，在一个正规的难民营，比如联合国难民营，会有这些——高高的围栏，有人记录谁进出。当我们问墨西哥官员关于这个营地的情况时，他们说他们不帮助这里的2500人，因为他们不想在这个地方设立永久性的帐篷城。他们希望人们搬到政府的收容所。
And the United Nations said they won't step in unless the Mexican government invites them to step in. The United States, whose policies landed people here in the first place, has also donated $5 million to house them in Mexico. The money doesn't go to tent camps like this one, but to the official Mexican government shelters.
联合国表示，除非墨西哥政府邀请，否则他们不会介入。美国，其政策首先将人们送到这里，也捐赠了500万美元用于他们在墨西哥的安置。但这笔钱不是给像这样的帐篷营地，而是给墨西哥政府的官方收容所。
It's enough money to shelter 8,000 people, but we sent way more people than that back across the border-- over 57,000 under the Remain in Mexico policy, plus another 21,000 who immigration officials haven't even begun to process. We've told them, the system's backed up. You should sit on a waiting list, stay in Mexico, and we'll get to your cases in a few months.
这笔钱足以安置8000人，但我们送回边境的人数远不止这些——根据“留在墨西哥”政策，已经超过57000人，另外还有21000人，移民官员甚至还没有开始处理。我们告诉他们，系统积压了。你应该在等待名单上等待，待在墨西哥，我们会在几个月内处理你们的案件。
And these were mostly people who, in the past, before President Trump, would have been allowed into the United States to wait for their asylum court dates here. It's so many people we're pushing back across the border, resulting in refugee camps that we don't call refugee camps right on our country's doorstep.
这些大多是过去在特朗普总统之前，会被允许进入美国等待庇护法庭日期的人。我们把太多人推回边境，导致在我们家门口出现了我们甚至不称之为难民营的难民营。
Today we try to understand what this new policy means for the people we send across the border. And we also hear from US officials who sent them there who are not feeling so great about it, themselves. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天，我们试图理解这项新政策对我们送往边境的人意味着什么。我们还会听到那些送他们过去、自己对此感到不太好受的美国官员的声音。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act one, "Goodbye, Stranger." So let's start today with the US officials on the front lines whose job under Remain in Mexico is to send people back. Lots of them have been resigning, saying no, that's actually not my job. Los Angeles Times reporter Molly O'Toole talked to a bunch of them.
第一幕，“再见，陌生人”。那么，让我们从今天身处前线的美国官员开始，他们在“留在墨西哥”政策下的工作是把人们遣返。许多人一直在辞职，说不，这实际上不是我的工作。《洛杉矶时报》记者莫莉·奥图尔和他们中的一些人谈过。
Before the Remain in Mexico policy began and upended the asylum system and completely changed what it is to be an asylum officer, here's how the job used to work. When a Central American showed up at the US-Mexico border and said, "let me in, I'm afraid of going back to my country," that's where the asylum officer came in.
在“留在墨西哥”政策开始并颠覆了庇护系统，彻底改变了庇护官员的含义之前，这份工作是这样运作的。当中美洲人在美墨边境出现并说“让我进去，我害怕回到我的国家”时，这就是庇护官员介入的地方。
The officer did something called a credible fear screening to check if the person was likely to face harm or death if the US sent them back home. If there's even a chance that they would, the asylum officer would let them into the United States to wait for a court date, where an immigration judge would make the final call.
官员会进行一种叫做“可信恐惧审查”的测试，检查如果美国将他们遣返回国，该人是否可能面临伤害或死亡。如果有一点可能，庇护官员会让他们进入美国等待开庭日期，由移民法官做出最终决定。
Doug Stephens says people don't understand how hard the job is. At the time all this started, he was an asylum officer in San Francisco.
道格·斯蒂芬斯说，人们不了解这份工作有多难。这一切开始时，他是旧金山的庇护官员。
And so I'd have people come into my office, and my job, essentially, is, tell me the worst things that have happened to you. You have an hour. Go. And then I'll decide if you're telling me the truth, and I'll decide if you get to stay.
所以，人们会来到我的办公室，我的工作基本上就是：告诉我你经历过的最糟糕的事情。你有一个小时。开始。然后我会决定你是否在说实话，我会决定你是否能留下来。
You are expected to be-- or, really, to do the job well, need to be-- an expert in the political, cultural, social, and economic situations in innumerable countries around the world, and you're expected to be a human lie detector, all at once.
你被期望成为——或者说，要做好这份工作，需要成为——世界上无数国家政治、文化、社会和经济状况的专家，同时你还被期望成为一个人体测谎仪。
President Trump talks about asylum itself as if it's fraud. He says it's a hoax, a big fat con job, that people come in with fake asylum claims, that asylum officers just let everyone through, and then asylum seekers never show up for their day in court-- that it's a border-wide, 2,000-mile loophole. And it's true that most people do pass that first stop with an asylum officer and enter the United States, but there's a good reason for that.
特朗普总统谈论庇护本身，好像那是一场骗局。他说这是一个骗局，一个巨大的谎言，人们带着虚假的庇护申请进来，庇护官员只是让每个人都通过，然后寻求庇护者永远不会在开庭日出现——这是一个边境范围内、2000英里长的漏洞。确实，大多数人通过了庇护官员的第一站并进入美国，但这有很好的理由。
It's built into US asylum law-- a commonsense humanitarian idea. We don't want to send people back to situations where they'd get tortured or killed. The legal term is non-refoulment. And so US law set the bar low. If there's basically any chance an asylum seeker could get killed or harmed, the officer is supposed to let them into the US, and doesn't need a lot of proof or evidence at that point.
这内置在美国庇护法中——一个通情达理的人道主义理念。我们不想把人们遣返回他们会被折磨或杀害的地方。法律术语是不推回原则。因此，美国法律把门槛定得很低。如果寻求庇护者基本上有任何可能被杀害或伤害，官员就应该让他们进入美国，此时并不需要太多的证据。
Later, when they get before an immigration judge-- and by the way, the majority do show up-- there they need proof, and most of them get rejected. Even before President Trump took office, less than 15% per year got asylum, and that's because most people don't meet the specific criteria in the law, or don't have enough evidence, or it doesn't check out. All of the asylum officers I've ever spoken with see it as their job to weed out the fakers, the people who don't really need protection, the ones who are just trying to game the system.
后来，当他们出现在移民法官面前时——顺便说一下，大多数人确实出现了——那里他们需要证据，而且大多数人被拒绝了。甚至在特朗普总统就职之前，每年获得庇护的比例不到15%，这是因为大多数人没有达到法律规定的具体标准，或者没有足够的证据，或者不符合条件。我采访过的所有庇护官员都把他们的工作视为剔除骗子，那些并不真正需要保护的人，那些只是试图操纵系统的人。
Oh my god. Like, here's where I'm going to be real with you.
天哪。在这里我要对你说实话。
This is an asylum officer we're calling Ursula. This isn't her voice. She's afraid of getting fired, so we had an actor copy what she said as closely as possible.
这是一位我们称之为乌苏拉的庇护官员。这不是她的声音。她害怕被解雇，所以我们让一位演员尽可能准确地复制了她所说的话。
The fraud is, like, happening on a scale that's huge. We're talking, like, hundreds of people a month.
欺诈行为正在发生，规模巨大。我们谈论的是每个月有数百人。
I interviewed three asylum officers for this story, and all three said the groups that have been the primary target of President Trump's immigration policies, they actually aren't the main ones committing fraud.
我采访了三位庇护官员，三人都说，一直是特朗普总统移民政策主要目标的人群，实际上并不是那些进行欺诈的主力。
It's not the Central Americans. It's not the Middle Eastern people. It is the Indian people and the Chinese people. They all have the same bullshit story about getting beaten with hockey sticks three times, because they're part of a Sikh party, and the police told them they're going to jail them if they ever bad-mouth the ruling party ever again. Bullshit.
不是中美洲人。不是中东人。而是印度人和中国人。他们都有同样愚蠢的故事，说因为他们是锡克教党的成员，被棍棒打了三次，警察告诉他们如果他们再敢诋毁执政党，就要把他们关进监狱。胡说八道。
They all just happened to do the same thing and suffer the same fate, even though there's absolutely no confirmation in any media that any of this persecution is happening, and studies done by our Department of State counterparts in the country are straight up like, this is not a real thing. The Chinese are running a similar scam with Christian claims.
他们都刚好做了同样的事，遭受了同样的命运，尽管没有任何媒体证实这种迫害正在发生，而且我们的国务院在当地的同事所做的研究也直接表明，这不是真的。中国人也在经营类似的基督教索赔骗局。
In the fall of 2018, asylum officers started hearing about these big changes coming. The policy that was first called Remain in Mexico, and then later, Migrant Protection Protocols, MPP. But the asylum officers who were going to have to implement this thing, they didn't know any of the details of how they were supposed to do it.
2018年秋天，庇护官员开始听到这些重大变革的消息。这项政策最初被称为“留在墨西哥”，后来被称为“移民保护协议”(MPP)。但那些将不得不实施这一政策的庇护官员，却不知道任何实施细节。
It was all shrouded in so much secrecy.
这一切都被笼罩在极大的秘密中。
This is another asylum officer. We're calling her Anne. We used an actor here, too, to protect her identity. Over the next few weeks, Anne starts picking up around the office that some of her colleagues were being called in quietly and asked to go to the border in San Diego.
这是另一位庇护官员。我们称她为安妮。我们也用了一名演员来保护她的身份。在接下来的几周里，安妮开始在办公室打听到，她的一些同事被悄悄叫去，要求去圣地亚哥的边境。
And instead of the credible fear screenings they'd always done, they seemed to be doing something entirely different under MPP-- a whole new kind of interview with different rules. She knew she was going to have to start doing them too, so she pulled aside a coworker who'd already been sent to the border.
他们似乎正在MPP下做完全不同的事情，而不是他们一直做的可信恐惧审查——一种全新的面试，规则也不同。她知道她也得开始做这些了，所以她把一个已经被派往边境的同事拉到一边。
I was asking her, hey, like, what's the training? Like, what is this? And she was like, I am not allowed to talk to you about it.
我问她，嘿，训练是什么？这是什么？她说，我不被允许和你谈论它。
Another asylum officer?
另一个庇护官员？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Is this someone who you'd, like, consider a friend, or just sort of, like, professional colleague?
这是你认为的朋友，还是仅仅是职业同事？
Good colleague-- a good colleague, someone that we had mutual trust, for sure, and then was told-- was brought in by a supervisor for, like, a special brief about it before I was going to start doing these interviews, and was told, here's the skinny on it and don't tell anyone.
很好的同事——一个好的同事，我们有共同的信任，这确实是真的。然后被上级叫去，进行了一个关于它的特别简报，在我开始做这些面试之前，被告知：这就是真相，不要告诉任何人。
Why?
为什么？
Because I think they knew that it was legally dubious and suspect, and they wanted to keep the leak to a minimum.
因为我认为他们知道这在法律上是可疑的，他们想把泄密控制在最低限度。
The leak being a major policy rollout that was going to change asylum?
泄密是指将改变庇护制度的重大政策发布？
Yeah.
是的。
That's the leak?
那是泄密？
That's the leak. Yeah.
那是泄密。是的。
Two months go by before they do a formal training session with the full asylum corps, and it's just a PowerPoint. Here's Ursula again.
两个月过去了，他们才给整个庇护官员队伍做了一个正式的培训，那只是一个PPT。乌苏拉又来了。
Hands we're going up and being like, wait, how is this legal, or how are we going to be doing this, and how do we know how this works?
有人举手说，等等，这怎么合法，或者我们将如何做，我们怎么知道它是怎么运作的？
All three of the asylum officers I talked to said that the presentation left them with lots of questions, including the biggest one, how is this legal? These officers knew better than almost anyone how dangerous Mexico is, and this policy seemed designed to send tons of people back to Mexico.
我采访的所有三位庇护官员都说，这份演示让他们有很多疑问，包括最大的一个：这怎么合法？这些官员比任何人都更了解墨西哥有多危险，而这项政策似乎就是为了把大量的人遣返回墨西哥。
It seemed to be in direct contradiction with US asylum law, which says that, at the very least, we can't send people back to a situation where they'd get harmed or killed. We can't violate the principle of non-refoulment.
这似乎与美国庇护法直接矛盾，该法律规定，至少我们不能把人们送回会被伤害或杀害的地方。我们不能违反不推回原则。
And the the response was like, I'm just the messenger bringing this down from HQ, and this is the PowerPoint they gave us. I was like, well, if you don't even care about double checking that this is legal, and you're just the messenger as you say, you're a fucking asshole, you know?
回应是，我只是把这从总部传达下来的信使，这就是他们给我们的PPT。我说，好吧，如果你连检查这是否合法都不在乎，你只是个信使，那你真是个混蛋，你知道吗？
All three officers say they raised concerns and got roughly the same response-- just get out there and do your job. What they found out soon enough was just how radical a change the new MPP interviews were from the old credible fear screenings.
三名官员都说他们提出了担忧，但得到的回复大致相同——出去做你的工作就行。他们很快发现，新的MPP面试与旧的可信恐惧审查之间的改变是多么激进。
For starters, not everyone would get an interview. Only the people who volunteered that they were scared to go back to Mexico would. If they got an interview, under MPP, asylum seekers would have to prove that they'd be harmed in Mexico, not their home country. And not just any harm-- they can't just be threatened by gangs or the police, they have to be threatened by gangs or police or whoever because of some very specific reasons laid out in the US law-- because of their nationality, race, religion, politics, or being part of a particular social group, like LGBTQ.
首先，不是每个人都会获得面试机会。只有那些自愿说他们害怕回墨西哥的人才会。如果他们参加面试，在MPP下，寻求庇护者必须证明他们在墨西哥会受到伤害，而不是在他们的原籍国。而且不仅仅是任何伤害——他们不能仅仅受到帮派或警察的威胁，他们必须因为美国法律规定的一些非常具体的原因而受到帮派或警察的威胁——因为他们的国籍、种族、宗教、政治或成为特定社会群体的一员，比如LGBTQ。
And they'd have to show that the Mexican government, like a cop or an official, was unable or unwilling to protect them. And the asylum seeker couldn't just say all this happened like they could under credible fear screenings. Now, they'd need to prove it.
他们必须证明墨西哥政府，比如警察或官员，无法或不愿保护他们。寻求庇护者不能像在可信恐惧审查下那样只说所有这一切发生了。现在，他们需要证明它。
It's like, as asylum seekers were traveling through Mexico fleeing for their lives, they should have been gathering evidence of all the screwed-up things happening to them there, making a paper trail. And they should have had all of this evidence on them right then, right after crossing the border, which, of course, is next to impossible, especially because they had no idea any of this was required.
这就像是，寻求庇护者在穿越墨西哥逃命时，应该收集在当地发生的所有糟糕事情的证据，制造一个书面记录。而且他们应该在刚过边境时就有所有这些证据，这当然是不可能的，特别是因为他们根本不知道需要这些。
Doug saw all of this happening and wanted nothing to do with it, so he tried to keep his head down to try and avoid having to do these interviews, hoping the courts would kill MPP, but they didn't. By June, MPP returns had skyrocketed, and it was all hands on deck for the asylum corps. Doug couldn't dodge it anymore.
道格看到了这一切发生，不想与此有任何关系，所以他试图保持低调，试图避免不得不做这些面试，希望法庭能终止MPP，但他们没有。到六月，MPP遣返数量激增，庇护官员队伍全力以赴。道格再也躲不开了。
And I got the email.
然后我收到了那封邮件。
It said, you're doing MPP interviews today.
上面写着，你今天要进行MPP面试。
So I had a father and son. The son, I think, was preteens, 11 or 12. They're fleeing from Honduras because of violence and other problems. We didn't talk about that much, because it doesn't matter for the purpose of MPP, right? I'm focused only on why they're afraid to go back to Mexico.
所以我遇到了一个父亲和儿子。儿子我想是青春期前，11或12岁。他们因为暴力和其他问题从洪都拉斯逃离。我们没有谈论那个，因为这在MPP的目的下无关紧要，对吧？我只关注他们为什么害怕回到墨西哥。
Of course, the guy and his son don't understand why they're even talking about Mexico. They don't understand any of this at all. The interview continued.
当然，那个男人和他的儿子不明白为什么他们在谈论墨西哥。他们根本不明白这一切。面试继续进行。
So he had tried to find a place to live there, had tried to get a work permit in Mexico, and was essentially denied. And as they're transiting, he's talking about, you know, encountering cartels and witnessing other migrants being murdered and tortured in front of his son, and fleeing, and barely getting away, you know, while death threats are being shouted at him, and, you know, talking about his son having nightmares for weeks because of this.
所以他尝试在当地找地方住，尝试在墨西哥获得工作许可，但基本上被拒绝了。当他们过境时，他谈到遇到贩毒集团，目睹其他移民在儿子面前被谋杀和折磨，逃跑，勉强脱险，你知道，当死亡威胁对着他叫喊时，谈到他的儿子因为这个做了几周噩梦。
And then, they get stopped by the police, and the police take all of their money, their cell phones, and because I can't get them to say these magic words of, like, yeah, they threatened me because I'm Honduran, but that's all they had to say. But they don't know that, right?
然后，他们被警察拦住，警察拿走了他们所有的钱，他们的手机。因为我无法让他们说出那句魔法咒语，比如“是的，他们威胁我是因为我是洪都拉斯人”——但他们只需要说这些就够了。但他们不知道，对吧？
Because I'm Honduran. Those would be the magic words that would put them in a protected category. They were targeted because of their nationality. Though even if the father had said because I'm Honduran, they probably still would have been sent back to Mexico, because odds are he didn't have any evidence proving that any of this happened. Doug, he did what the policy told him to do. He sent them back to Mexico.
因为我是洪都拉斯人。那些就是把他们置于受保护类别的魔法咒语。他们被盯上是因为他们的国籍。虽然即使那个父亲说了“因为我是洪都拉斯人”，他们很可能还是会被遣返回墨西哥，因为很可能他没有任何证据证明这一切发生过。道格，他按照政策告诉他的做了。他把他们遣返回了墨西哥。
The old credible fear screenings usually took an hour or less. These MPP interviews can last four, five, six hours. When I asked these asylum officers to describe what these interviews are like for them, for the migrants in front of them, Ursula gave the most vivid picture.
旧的可信恐惧审查通常需要一个小时或更少。这些MPP面试可能持续四个、五个、六个小时。当我要求这些庇护官员描述这些面试对他们和面前的移民意味着什么时，乌苏拉给出了最生动的画面。
She told me about the very first MPP interview she did-- a family from El Salvador, two parents and two kids. She had a script she had to stick to. The family was exhausted and traumatized and totally unprepared.
她告诉我她做的第一次MPP面试——一个来自萨尔瓦多的家庭，两个父母和两个孩子。她有一个必须坚持的剧本。这家人精疲力竭，受到创伤，完全没有准备。
You're put into a cell. You're separated from your kids and your wife. You have no idea what's going on, because you thought today you were going to be interviewed about El Salvador and you were going to get to enter the United States.
你被关进牢房。你和你的孩子、妻子被分开。你根本不知道发生了什么，因为你以为今天会被问关于萨尔瓦多的问题，你就可以进入美国。
A couple hours later, they lead you into this freezing cold cell where they chain your hands to a table in handcuffs, and someone is sitting across from you who doesn't speak your language, and starts talking to someone in the phone who starts translating to you that you're going to talk about Mexico. You smell like shit, because you've been living in a shelter, you know, without any running water for a month and half, plus you've traveled all the way across Central America to get there, and you don't understand why someone is talking to you about Mexico.
几个小时后，他们带你进入这个冰冷的牢房，用手铐把你锁在桌子上，一个不会说你语言的人坐在你对面，开始和电话里的人通话，那人翻译给你听，说你要谈论墨西哥。你闻起来像屎，因为你在一个没有自来水的收容所待了一个半月，而且你穿越了整个中美洲才到那里，你不明白为什么有人要和你谈论墨西哥。
This interview goes on for an hour and a half, and the person keeps pausing it so they can talk to someone on the computer, which they say is their supervisor, and another guard leads your wife in that you haven't seen in the last 12 hours into the interview room, and you can, you know, brush her hand as she passes by. You're so happy to see her because you've been separated, and you have no idea what's going on.
这次面试持续了一个半小时，那个人不停地暂停，这样他们就可以和电脑上的人说话，他们说是他们的上司。另一个守卫把你过去12小时没见过的妻子带进面试室，当你经过时，你可以碰一下她的手。你见到她很高兴，因为你们分开了，你根本不知道发生了什么。
So, where are my children? I don't know, sir, I'm sure they'll be fine. Your wife goes through a similar interview, but she keeps being confronted about the answers she's giving because they're different from yours, and the officer can't understand why this story varies so differently between two people who experienced it.
那么，我的孩子在哪里？我不知道，先生，我相信他们会没事的。你的妻子经历了类似的面试，但她不停地被问到她给出的答案，因为答案和你的不一样，官员不明白为什么两个亲身经历这件事的人的故事会有这么大的差异。
Half an hour passes before her children are brought into the room, and then the officer has to talk to a 10-year-old boy about whatever his parents said, and then confront the 10-year-old boy on inconsistencies between his story and his parents' story. And then, the wife is like, when am I going to see my husband again? And the officer's like, I have no idea, let them know if you need to use the bathroom.
半小时过去，她的孩子被带进房间，然后官员必须和一个10岁的男孩谈论他父母说的任何话，然后当面质问10岁男孩，关于他的故事和父母故事之间的不一致。然后，妻子问：我什么时候能再见到我的丈夫？官员说：我不知道，如果需要上厕所就让他们知道。
Ursula made the case that the family shouldn't get sent back to Mexico, and, to her shock, her supervisor agreed. In fact, she happened to walk outside the moment the family got released. They've got their backpacks on. They're holding hands. She thought, maybe this won't be so bad. But that was the last time. The very next interview, a woman told her over and over she was afraid of being raped and killed in Mexico. Ursula believed she was going back to a place where that was very possible, but because the woman couldn't name a specific person who'd assault her, Ursula had to send her back. Since then, it's essentially been no after no after no.
乌苏拉提出了这家人不应该被遣返回墨西哥的理由，让她震惊的是，她的上司同意了。事实上，她碰巧在家人被释放的那一刻走到了外面。他们背着背包，手拉着手。她想，也许这不会那么糟。但那是最后一次。下一次面试，一个女人反复告诉她，她害怕在墨西哥被强奸和杀害。乌苏拉相信她要回到一个非常可能发生这种事的地方，但因为那个女人说不出具体是谁会袭击她，乌苏拉不得不把她送回去。从那以后，基本上就是不断的拒绝。
Asylum officers told me that even when they find one of those unicorn cases where they check off all the boxes and recommend not returning to Mexico, their supervisors overrule them. Anne told me and my producer, Nadia Reiman, about one asylum seekers case where their attacker even spelled out their motive, and it still didn't fly.
庇护官员告诉我，即使当他们发现那些满足了所有条件并建议不要送回墨西哥的“独角兽案例”时，他们的上司也会推翻他们的决定。安妮向我和我的制片人纳迪亚·雷曼讲述了一个寻求庇护者的案例，袭击者甚至说出了动机，但这仍然行不通。
It was basically a situation where there was a really clear connection to the nationality. Like, the persecutor had, like, really said, like, I am harming you because of this nationality-- your nationality. And the harm was really, really severe. It was, like, definitely torture.
这基本上是一个与国籍有非常明确联系的情况。例如，迫害者确实说过，“我伤害你是为了这个国籍——你的国籍”。而且伤害确实非常非常严重。那绝对是折磨。
And it was really clear that the police, like, weren't going to do a thing about it-- didn't care at all. And the supervisor rejected it.
而且很明显，警察根本不会对此做任何事——完全不在乎。上司拒绝了。
Why? Like, did they say why?
为什么？他们说了原因吗？
They said, we can't show that if this individual went back to Mexico, the persecutor would be able to locate them.
他们说，我们无法证明如果这个人回到墨西哥，迫害者是否有能力找到他们。
So the standard today is upside down from what it used to be under credible fear. Instead of, let's err on the side of letting people in because we don't want anyone to be tortured or die, under MPP the standard is almost impossibly high, so almost nobody gets in. The Department of Homeland Security says only about 960 people interviewed have not been sent back to Mexico.
所以今天的标准与以前的可信恐惧审查正好相反。与其倾向于让人们进来，因为我们不想让任何人被折磨或死亡，在MPP下，标准高得离谱，所以几乎没有人能进来。国土安全部称，只有约960名接受面试的人没有被遣返回墨西哥。
Ultimately, of a little more than 47,000 MPP cases registered as of October, with about 37,000 of those still pending, of those, only 11 people have been granted asylum or some other kind of relief, according to Syracuse University, which tracks all of this using government statistics. 11.
最终，据雪城大学使用政府统计数据的追踪，截至10月登记的47000多起MPP案件中，约37000起仍处于挂起状态，只有11人获得了庇护或其他救济。11个。
And that's what the policy was meant to do. The administration credits MPP for a sharp drop in the numbers coming to the border. Mark Morgan, the acting head of Customs and Border Protection, calls it a game changer, and absolutely successful.
这就是这项政策的目的。政府将边境人数的急剧下降归功于MPP。海关和边境保护局代理局长马克·摩根称这是一个游戏规则的改变者，是绝对成功的。
It only took Doug two days and five interviews to go home after work and pull out the law books. He's a lawyer. He actually owned a beat-up copy of the Immigration and Nationality Act, the law hundreds of pages long that makes it the foundation of the US immigration system.
道格工作结束后回家，翻出法律书籍只用了两天和五次面试。他是一名律师。他实际上拥有一本磨损的《移民与国籍法》，这是一部数百页的法律，是美国移民体系的基础。
He grabbed that off his bedroom shelf, along with a few of his other books from law school. He printed out a bunch of court cases and Supreme Court decisions with more cases pulled up on his computer screen. In the middle of all of this was his pen and white legal pad.
他从卧室架子上拿下了那本书，还有几本他法学院的书。他打印出一堆法庭案例和最高法院的决定，电脑屏幕上还打开着更多的案例。在这中间是他的一支钢笔和白色法律记事本。
As an attorney, he wanted to get his feelings about MPP-- how much worse it felt compared to everything else they did-- down in writing. He worked for hours, and he wrote down seven bullet points, the main ways he thought MPP was illegal. Once he saw the list laid out there on the lined white paper, Doug knew what to do. The next day, he went to tell his supervisor he wasn't going to do any more MPP interviews.
作为律师，他想把自己对MPP的感受——与其他工作相比，这让他感觉有多糟糕——写下来。他工作了几个小时，写下了七个要点，他认为MPP非法的最主要原因。一旦他看到这份列在横线白纸上的清单，道格就知道该怎么做了。第二天，他去告诉上司他不会再做任何MPP面试了。
His response was, I know these interviews are hard. We're all required to do them. That's why we're trying to spread it out, that it's, you know, on a rolling basis, et cetera, et cetera. And, you know, at that point, there was, like, this moment where I could have just said, you're right, I know, this sucks, and gone back.
他的回答是，我知道这些面试很难。我们都必须做这些。这就是为什么我们要试图把它分散开来，它是滚动基础的，等等等等。然后，在那一点上，我曾有过一个时刻，我本可以只说，你是对的，我知道，这太糟糕了，然后回去。
And I paused, and I told him, you don't understand. I'm not doing these interviews. And he looked at me and he's like, what do you-- you're not doing these interviews? And I was like, no. I was like, I think they're illegal. They're definitely immoral, and I'm not doing them.
我停顿了一下，告诉他：你不明白。我不会做这些面试。他看着我，就像是说：你什么意思？你不做这些面试？我说，不。我说，我认为它们是非法的。它们绝对是不道德的，我不会做它们。
His boss was stunned. He didn't really seem to know what to say. Eventually, he told him he was probably going to have to write him up somehow to start disciplinary proceedings. Doug went home that night and decided to escalate. He went back to his legal pad.
他的老板惊呆了。他似乎真的不知道该说什么。最终，他告诉他，他可能不得不以某种方式写处分报告，启动纪律处分程序。道格那天晚上回家，决定升级此事。他回到他的法律记事本前。
I essentially wrote a legal memo explaining all of the reasons that I thought it was illegal, and why I was refusing to do it. And then, on that Monday, I emailed that to all of the administration in San Francisco, and the two supervisors that were involved in the disciplinary proceedings.
我基本上写了一份法律备忘录，解释了我认为它非法的所有理由，以及我拒绝做它的原因。然后，在那个星期一，我把它发邮件给了旧金山所有的管理层，以及参与纪律处分程序的两位上司。
And then, nothing. Nothing happened. Instead of sparking some kind of rebellion, or at least forcing a confrontation, it's crickets. So he took it a step further.
然后，什么都没有。什么都没发生。没有引发某种反抗，或者至少强迫一场对抗，而是鸦雀无声。所以他更进一步。
He sent his memo to a senator's office, then he drafted his goodbye email, attached his memo, and sent it out office-wide to all of San Francisco Asylum, about 80 people, and to a representative of the union for asylum officers across the country. And with that, Doug shut down his work computer and walked out. He quit.
他把他的备忘录发给了参议员的办公室，然后起草了他的告别邮件，附上他的备忘录，发给了整个旧金山庇护办公室，大约80人，以及全国庇护官员工会的代表。就这样，道格关掉了他的工作电脑，走了出来。他辞职了。
They make one change, and everyone at the office is like, oh, this is terrible, but we'll figure it out. And then they make another change. And they're like, oh, this is terrible, but I need my job. I'm going to do it even if I don't want to, and I'll complain about it, and I'll complain about the work, and I'll complain about the hours.
他们做出一个改变，办公室里每个人都说：哦，这太可怕了，但我们会想办法。然后他们又做出另一个改变。他们又说：哦，这太可怕了，但我需要这份工作。即使我不想要，我也要去做，我会抱怨，我会抱怨工作，我会抱怨工时。
At the end of the day, I'm going to do it, and the more I do it, the easier it is to do. And that is terrifying. I mean, that's how all of the awful things in the world have happened. That's how you get so many good people doing really bad things.
到头来，我还是会去做，而且我做得越多，做起来就越容易。这太可怕了。我的意思是，世界上所有可怕的事情都是这样发生的。这就是为什么会有这么多好人做着非常糟糕的事情。
And that's what's happening, and it's terrifying. You're, like, literally sending people back to be raped and killed. That's what this is.
而这就是正在发生的事情，这太可怕了。你简直是在把人们遣返回去遭受强奸和杀害。这就是它的本质。
The three officers I spoke with are not alone. A union representing the asylum officers and USCIS employees filed a brief and a lawsuit against the administration arguing that MPP was illegal, and a ton of officers are quitting. I've heard this from a bunch of people in the asylum corps, and at Citizenship and Immigration Services, the parent agency.
我采访的三位官员并不孤单。代表庇护官员和美国公民及移民服务局员工的工会提起诉讼，反对政府，辩称MPP是非法的，而且有很多官员正在辞职。我从庇护官员队伍和作为母机构的公民及移民服务局的许多人那里听到了这一点。
Several used the word, exodus. And if officers can't quit, they're calling in sick-- anything they can do to avoid MPP interviews. We tried to get some numbers from the government.
几个人用了“大逃亡”这个词。如果官员不能辞职，他们就会请病假——任何他们能做的来避免MPP面试的事情。我们试图从政府那里得到一些数字。
They wouldn't tell us how many people had left. They did say that, by the end of the year, they hoped to have 771 asylum officers, but as of a month ago, they had something like 550, meaning they're roughly 200 people short. I tried to get an interview with the acting head of USCIS, Ken Cuccinelli, to talk about all this. He's since been named Deputy Homeland Security Secretary.
他们没有告诉我们有多少人离开了。他们的确说，到年底，他们希望有771名庇护官员，但一个月前，他们大约只有550人，这意味着他们少了大约200人。我试图采访美国公民及移民服务局的代理局长肯·库奇内利，谈论这一切。他后来被任命为国土安全部副部长。
He didn't give us one, but I did get one question in. It was at a press breakfast, so this audio was recorded on my phone.
他没有接受采访，但我还是问了一个问题。那是在一个新闻早餐会上，所以这段录音是我在手机上录的。
All right, Molly O'Toole from the Los Angeles Times.
好的，我是《洛杉矶时报》的莫莉·奥图尔。
How do you answer the concerns from some of your asylum officers-- their concerns that many of these policies being handed down by the Trump administration, particularly targeting asylum, are in fact, illegal-- that they're being ordered to implement policies that are in direct contradiction with immigration laws that are passed by Congress?
你如何回答来自你一些庇护官员的担忧——他们担心特朗普政府下达的许多政策，特别是针对庇护的政策，实际上是非法的——他们被命令实施与国会通过的移民法直接矛盾的政策？
Well, they're not in direct contradiction, or we wouldn't be utilizing them. We have 19,000 people that work with USCIS. I don't expect any two of us to completely agree on all of this, but I do expect that the professional employees at USCIS will implement the policies in place. They're part of the--
好吧，它们没有直接矛盾，否则我们就不会使用它们了。我们在美国公民及移民服务局有19000人。我不指望我们中的任何两个人能完全同意这一切，但我确实期望美国公民及移民服务局的专业员工将实施现行的政策。他们是……的一部分。
They're part of the executive branch, he said, and so long as we're in the position of putting in place what we believe to be legal policies that haven't been found to be otherwise, we fully expect them to implement those faithfully and sincerely and vigorously.
他说，他们是行政部门的一部分，只要我们处于实施我们认为是合法的且未被发现是违法的政策的位置，我们就完全期望他们忠诚、真诚且有力地实施这些政策。
Now, we're just shy of MPP's first birthday. After a chaotic start, it's thousands returned each week, it's expanded all the way east across the US border from California to Texas' Gulf Coast. And it's not just Central Americans being pushed back. Now, it's Cubans, Venezuelans, pregnant women, LGBTQ.
现在，离MPP一周岁还差一点。经过混乱的开始，每周有数千人被遣返，它已经从加利福尼亚向东横跨美国边境，一直延伸到德克萨斯的墨西哥湾沿岸。而且不仅仅是中美洲人被推回去。现在是古巴人、委内瑞拉人、孕妇、LGBTQ。
Asylum, at least at the southern border, has essentially ground to a halt. Here's Anne.
庇护，至少在南部边境，基本上陷入了停滞。这是安妮说的。
I'll say this. Like, the administration's been successful.
我要说这一点。政府成功了。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
They want negative decisions. They don't want asylum seekers in this country. They don't want people to get positive decisions or determinations for asylum. They have felt that the standards for screening interviews were too low, and they wanted those standards changed and those standards raised, and they've succeeded.
他们想要否定的决定。他们不想要寻求庇护者在这个国家。他们不想要人们获得正面的决定或判定。他们觉得筛选面试的标准太低了，他们想改变标准并提高标准，而且他们成功了。
What do you think the administration's end goal is?
你认为政府的最终目标是什么？
No more people from shithole countries.
不要再有来自“屎坑国家”的人了。
Anne throws up in the shower almost every day. She has recurring nightmares. She says she can't focus, can't sleep. She thinks about the people she's returned to Mexico all the time. It's nearly 100. But there's one family in particular that she can't stop thinking about, a father and son.
安妮几乎每天在淋浴时都会呕吐。她有反复发作的噩梦。她说她无法集中注意力，无法睡觉。她一直都在想那些被她遣返回墨西哥的人。近100个了。但有一个家庭让她特别无法停止思考，一个父亲和儿子。
Why do you think their case sticks with you?
为什么你认为他们的案例一直缠绕着你？
The kid was really young. What happened to him? Did this kid get kidnapped? Did he get murdered? It's happening. It's happening a lot.
那个孩子非常小。他发生了什么事？这个孩子被绑架了吗？他被谋杀了吗？这正在发生。经常发生。
What was that?
那是什么？
And the-- what's my moral culpability in that? I interviewed that case, and my signature is on that paperwork, and that's something now that I live with. So yeah, I feel-- I feel in some ways that this administration's made me a human rights abuser.
还有我的道德责任是什么？我面试了那个案例，我的签名在那份文件上，这是我现在必须忍受的事情。所以是的，我在某种程度上感到政府让我成为了一个人权侵犯者。
The irony of this policy is that, under our asylum law, to qualify for asylum, you have to have been harmed because you're part of a particular group, a certain class of people. And the way that the asylum officers have implemented MPP, they've created exactly that-- a huge group of people in need of protection, about 60,000 migrants forced by the US back to Mexico to be preyed upon there as they wait on their request for safety in the US.
这项政策的讽刺之处在于，根据我们的庇护法，要获得庇护资格，你必须因为是一个特定群体、一类人而受到伤害。而庇护官员实施MPP的方式，恰恰创造了这一点——一个庞大的、需要保护的群体，大约60000名移民被美国强迫遣返回墨西哥，在等待美国对他们安全请求的回应时，在那里成为猎物。
It's exactly the sort of situation that our law was supposed to prevent. One asylum officer told me, it's the first time that we've been asked to affirmatively do harm to people. You're not just saying, I don't think you're eligible. You're literally saying, I believe what you're saying. I think you're in danger. Go back to that danger.
这正是我们法律本应防止的情况。一位庇护官员告诉我，这是我们第一次被要求积极主动地伤害人们。你不只是在说，我不认为你符合条件。你实际上是在说：我相信你所说的话。我认为你处于危险之中。回到那个危险中去吧。
Molly O'Toole covers immigration for the Los Angeles Times. She wrote a print version of this story, also. It's at their website.
莫莉·奥图尔为《洛杉矶时报》报道移民事务。她也写了这个故事的印刷版。可以在他们的网站上找到。
Coming up, what's it sound like when the cartels get on the phone and bargain with your family for your life? We have recordings. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，当贩毒集团打电话用你的生命与你的家人讨价还价时，听起来是什么样的？我们有录音。这是芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续后的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "The Out Crowd," stories about the people-- the tens of thousands of them-- who have been pushed into Mexico by the President's Remain in Mexico policy and other policies. We're talking about what happens to those people as they wait in Mexico for months.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，“局外人群”，讲述那些人——成千上万的人——被总统的“留在墨西哥”政策和其他政策推入墨西哥的故事。我们谈论的是那些人在墨西哥等待数月时发生了什么。
And before we get to the next act, there is another thing that the Trump administration has put in place that makes it a lot harder to get asylum here, something we haven't talked about yet, a new rule that went into effect this summer. It says, if you want asylum in the United States, you first have to apply for asylum in at least one of the countries that you passed through on your way here, and you have to get rejected by that country before we'll give you asylum here in the United States.
在我们进入下一幕之前，还有另一件事是特朗普政府实施的，这使得在这里获得庇护难得多，我们还没谈过这件事，今年夏天生效的一项新规则。它说，如果你想在美国寻求庇护，你必须首先在你来这里的路上经过的至少一个国家申请庇护，而且必须被那个国家拒绝，我们才会给你美国庇护。
Many asylum seekers, of course, have no idea that they're required to do this. When I was in Matamoros at that tent camp, this come up with that woman, Jenny from Honduras, the one who got worried about the cartel guy listening in on her interview, the one who'd been kidnapped. She was saying that her court date in the United States to get asylum was coming up on November 26th, and she'd been waiting since mid-August. She thought she had a good case, and was hopeful.
当然，许多寻求庇护者根本不知道他们被要求这样做。当我在马塔莫罗斯那个帐篷营地时，这出现在那个洪都拉斯妇女珍妮身上，那个担心贩毒集团监听她采访的女人，那个被绑架过的人。她说她在美申请庇护的日期是11月26日，她从8月中旬就开始等待。她认为她有个好案例，充满希望。
Have you applied for asylum in Mexico?
你在墨西哥申请过庇护吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
No. No. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
不。没有。[西班牙语]
No, no, not here, because it's too dangerous here.
不，不，不在这里，因为这里太危险了。
My co-worker Aviva and I looked at each other, like, does she know about the new rule? So we asked, and she did know that she was supposed to apply for asylum in Mexico or in Guatemala, which she'd passed through, but she wasn't going to do it, she said. She didn't want to live there.
我和同事阿维娃面面相觑，她知道新规则吗？我们问了，她确实知道她应该在墨西哥或她经过的危地马拉申请庇护，但她说她不会做。她不想住在那里。
Are you worried that that'll keep you from getting asylum in the United States?
你担心那会阻碍你获得美国庇护吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Yeah, I think so, because from what I've heard, we needed to have asked for asylum in the neighboring countries.
是的，我想是的，因为据我所知，我们需要在邻国申请庇护。
At that point, we all just kind of look down at the ground and avoid eye contact. Nobody knows what to say. It sounds so bad for her.
在那一刻，我们都只是看向地面，避免眼神接触。没人知道该说什么。这对她来说太糟糕了。
In fact, for everybody in the camp, all 2,500 of them who are waiting for months for the court dates hoping for asylum, it's easy to imagine that this one rule would kill all their applications. Jenny's attitude was, I'm just going to cross my fingers and hope for the best, because I don't want to go back home. Things seem too dangerous there, and too dangerous in Mexico, too. Lots of people feel that way.
事实上，对于营地里的每个人，所有那2500名等待数月希望通过庇护申请法庭日期的人来说，很容易想象这一条规定会扼杀他们所有的申请。珍妮的态度是：我只是祈祷并希望一切顺利，因为我不想回老家。那里看起来太危险，墨西哥也太危险了。很多人都有这种感觉。
And the danger in Mexico is the subject of act two, which we have arrived at now. Act two, "Take the Long Way Home." If you had to pick which border city in Mexico is the most dangerous, Nuevo Laredo, right across the border from Laredo, Texas, would be a good contender.
而墨西哥的危险是第二幕的主题，我们现在到了。第二幕，“走远路回家”。如果你必须选出墨西哥哪个边境城市最危险，德克萨斯州拉雷多对面的新拉雷多将是一个很好的竞争者。
The State Department classifies it as level four threat. That is the same threat level as Iraq and Syria. And a lot of the danger there is kidnapping.
国务院将其归类为四级威胁。这与伊拉克和叙利亚的威胁等级相同。那里有很多危险是绑架。
Kidnapping is so prevalent there that one of our producers met men in a migrant shelter who were terrified to go outside. A young Cuban guy told her, just putting one foot outside the shelter makes him worried. A trip of just two minutes, he's looking all around, and he's scared.
绑架在那里如此普遍，以至于我们的一位制片人在一个移民收容所遇到了男人，他们吓得不敢出去。一个古巴小伙告诉她，只要在收容所外面迈出一只脚，他就会担心。仅仅两分钟的路程，他都要四处张望，而且他很害怕。
We're interested in these kidnappings because they're so common. Reporter Emily Green went to Nuevo Laredo in August, and she has this story about one kidnapping and what happened to one family, including recordings and details you really never get to hear. This family ended up in Nuevo Laredo because of MPP. Here's Emily.
我们对这些绑架感兴趣，因为它们太普遍了。记者艾米丽·格林在八月去了新拉雷多，她有关于一次绑架以及一个家庭发生的事情的故事，包括你真的永远听不到的录音和细节。这个家庭因为MPP最终来到新拉雷多。这是艾米丽。
This guy who got kidnapped, I met him by chance, actually, before he got kidnapped, and he told me how scared he was that he would get kidnapped. I was on a bridge in Nuevo Laredo that connects Mexico to the US. Every day around 1:00 PM that month, the US was sending back migrants from the US side to Mexico under MPP.
这个被绑架的家伙，我是在他被绑架前偶然遇到的，他告诉我他有多担心自己会被绑架。我在连接墨西哥和美国的一座桥上。那个月每天下午1点左右，美国都在根据MPP将移民从美国边境遣返回墨西哥。
That day, there were a hundred of them. They were easy to spot. They all carried clear plastic bags with a couple of documents in them, and none of them had shoelaces. US Immigration takes shoelaces from anyone they detain.
那天有100个人。他们很容易辨认。他们都拎着透明塑料袋，里面有几份文件，而且他们都没有鞋带。美国移民局会从所有拘留的人身上取走鞋带。
Most of them were men, many of them with their heads down, and one pair stands out to me-- a father and son in matching polo shirts, both of them sweating in the heat. They're chubby, soft faces, dad has his arm around son. They seem like they'll talk to me. The man, I'll call him David, quickly tells me a story.
大多数是男人，许多人低着头，一对父子引起了我的注意——穿着配套的Polo衫，两人都在热浪中流汗。他们脸庞胖嘟嘟的，软绵绵的，爸爸搂着儿子的胳膊。他们看起来愿意跟我说话。这个男人，我会叫他大卫，很快告诉了我一个故事。
No soy delinquente Soy una persona que ha ganado la vida pero ya no puedo vivir en mi país. Eso es lo que pasa.
我不是罪犯。我是一个为了生活而努力的人，但我无法再生活在我的国家。这就是正在发生的事。
He says he's not a criminal. He's a person who's always made a living, but he can't live in his country anymore. They're from Honduras. David was a businessman. He ran a little clothing store.
他说他不是罪犯。他是一个一直靠努力生活的人，但现在无法再生活在自己的国家。他们来自洪都拉斯。大卫是个生意人。他经营一家小服装店。
The gangs there demand money. They call it a war tax. The tax kept hitting higher and higher until David's family couldn't pay it anymore. One night, the cartel broke into his house, threatened to rape his daughter, and so they fled.
当地的帮派要求钱。他们称之为“战争税”。税额越来越高，直到大卫的家庭再也付不起了。一天晚上，贩毒集团闯入他家，威胁要强奸他的女儿，于是他们逃走了。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
I've done lots of interviews with people like David, migrants in really difficult situations. This one felt especially hard. I think just seeing a father fall apart in front of his 11-year-old son.
我和大卫这样的人做过很多采访，他们是处境非常困难的移民。这一个感觉特别困难。我想只是看到一个父亲在他11岁儿子面前崩溃。
Nunca me escucharon. Solo me dieron los documentos para venir a una cita aquí pero yo no puedo regresar más a Honduras.
他们从不听我说。他们只是给了我文件，让我来这里参加面试，但我再也不能回到洪都拉斯了。
David says he wanted to ask for asylum in the US, but the agents didn't listen to him. They just gave him documents to come back to a court date in December. He can't go back to Honduras, he says.
大卫说他想申请美国庇护，但特工们没听他的。他们只是给了他文件，让他回墨西哥等待12月的开庭日期。他说，他不能回到洪都拉斯。
No tengo donde ir. No tengo nada. No tengo dinero. A mi me dicen aqui en esta lado donde vamos a pasar dicen que secuestran mucha la gente y no se que hacer.
我没地方去。我什么都没有。我没钱。他们在这一侧告诉我，我们要去的地方绑架很多人，我不知道该怎么办。
I don't have anywhere to go. I don't have anything. I don't have money, he says. They say that here, where we're being sent, a lot of people get kidnapped, and I don't know what to do.
我们只谈了10分钟。我最后借给了他我的手机。他打给了在新泽西州的妹妹，解释了发生的事情——他到了美国，结果却被送回了墨西哥。
We only talked for 10 minutes. I ended up lending him my phone. He called his sister in New Jersey and explained what happened-- that he made it to the United States only to be sent back to Mexico.
天快黑了，我被告知不要在新拉雷多待到天黑后。我回到美国去吃晚饭，离我上次见到大卫的地方可能不到一英里，我的手机响了。是大卫的妹妹。我会叫她劳拉。
It was getting dark out, and I'd been told not to stay in Nuevo Laredo past dusk. I crossed back into the US to go to dinner, probably not a mile away from where I'd last seen David, and my phone rang. It was David's sister. I'll call her Laura.
她有我的号码，因为他今天早些时候是用我的手机给她打的电话。她哭得太厉害，我很难理解她在说什么。她告诉我，就在我离开他们几小时后，大卫和他的儿子就被绑架了。她接到了一个贩毒集团要求赎金的电话。
She had my number because it was my phone he called her from earlier today. She was crying so hard I struggled to understand what she was saying. She tells me David and his son had been kidnapped just hours after I'd left them. She'd gotten a call from a cartel demanding ransom.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
劳拉说贩毒集团告诉她，大卫的赎金是9000美元，他儿子的赎金也是9000美元，总共18000美元。他们让大卫简短地接了电话，让她知道他还活着，然后绑架者接过了电话。
Laura says of the cartel told her the ransom was $9,000 for David, and another $9,000 for his son, so $18,000 total. They put David on the phone briefly so she knew he was alive, and then the kidnappers got on.
我告诉他，我们从哪里能弄到钱……
Yo le dije a él que nosotros de adonde íbamos a sacar el dinero...
好的。
OK.
他们只是告诉我必须寄钱，明天还会打给我。
Solo me dijeron que tenía que mandar y que mañana me van a llamar.
我告诉他们，我们去哪里弄这笔钱？另一端的男人告诉她，她必须弄到钱。他说明天会再打来。我让劳拉录下这些通话。
And I told them, where in the world are we going to get this money? The man on the other end told her she had to get the money. He said he'd call back tomorrow. I asked Laura to record the phone calls.
她照做了。第二天他们打来时，她用了免提，并用亲戚的手机拍了录像。
And she did. When they called the next day, she put them on speaker and used a relative's phone to shoot video of it.
我什么都没有。我们没有钱，小伙子。你看看我们现在多么紧张。我甚至病了。
Es que no tengo nada. Nosotros no tenemos dinero muchacho. Viera como estamos ahorita de los nervios. Estoy más bien enferma.
他们告诉她，“我需要你尽快存钱，老太婆。”“老太婆”意思是老女人。劳拉38岁。她再次告诉他们她没钱，因为焦虑而病了。
They tell her, I need you to deposit the money as soon as possible, viejita. Viejita means, old lady. Laura is 38. She tells them again that she has no money, that she's sick from anxiety.
在和我通话时，劳拉很害怕，在哭，但当她和绑架者交谈时，她保持镇定。她问大卫和儿子还好吗。绑架者告诉她，他们现在有东西吃，可以洗澡。每次通话只持续几分钟。
In her conversations with me, Laura is scared, crying, but when she talked to the kidnappers, she holds it together. She asks if David and his son are OK. The kidnappers tell her they have food, that they can bathe, for now. Each call only last a few minutes.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
到了第三天，贩毒集团将大卫和他儿子的价格降到了每人5000美元。劳拉在新泽西州的一家印刷厂做夜班，一年很难挣到20000美元，而且她还是个单身母亲。
By the third day, the cartel has lowered the price to $5,000 each for David and his son. Laura works the night shift at a printing factory in New Jersey, hardly makes $20,000 in a year, plus she's a single mom.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
在所有这些通话中，绑架者说话速度极快，我猜是因为他们还有其他的赎金电话要打。绑架是一门大生意，一个量大生意，有着完整的基础设施。绑架移民在墨西哥已经很常见很长时间了。
In all of these calls, the kidnappers talk super fast, I'm guessing because they have other ransom calls to make. Kidnapping is a big business, a volume business, with a whole infrastructure. Kidnapping migrants has been common in Mexico for a long time.
现在不同的是，美国使贩毒集团识别和抓捕受害者变得特别容易。他们成群结队地遣返寻求庇护者，每天同一时间，而且他们很容易识别，带着塑料袋和丢失的鞋带。国土安全部没有回应我关于绑架情况的评论请求，但本周海关和边境保护局代理局长表示，美国正在“向犯罪组织发送一个信息，停止剥削这些移民。”
What's different now is that the US is making it especially easy for the cartels to identify and snatch victims. They're sending asylum seekers back in big groups, all at once, at the same time each day, and they're easy to identify with their plastic bags and missing shoelaces. Homeland Security didn't respond to my request for comment on the kidnapping situation, but this week the acting head of Customs and Border Protection said the US is, quote, "sending a message to the criminal organizations to stop exploiting these migrants."
在新拉雷多，这些寻求庇护者旅途中最危险的部分可能是被遣返回墨西哥后的那几个小时。步行过桥后，他们被货车送到墨西哥移民局。办公室外面，四门卡车里的男人监视着谁进谁出。
In Nuevo Laredo, the most dangerous part of these asylum seekers' journey is probably the hours right after they've been sent back to Mexico. After walking across the bridge, they're transported to the Mexican Immigration Office by van. Outside the office, men in four-door trucks monitor who's coming and going.
当地人称他们为“坏家伙”。一个移民告诉我，当他从那里走到收容所时遭到追逐。但到目前为止，最危险的地方是车站。
Locals call them, Los Malos, the bad guys. One migrant told me about getting chased as he walked to a shelter from there. But by far, the most dangerous place is a bus station.
那是他们逃离新拉雷多的地方，但也是他们最终被抓住的地方。绑架如此常规，以至于贩毒集团将其称为“通过办公室”。在勒索电话中，你可以听出这是一个运转良好的机器。它是条理清晰的。他们听起来像是在商量一辆车的价格。他们一直这样做。
It's a place they go to escape Nuevo Laredo, but it's a place they end up getting caught. Kidnapping is so routine the cartels refer to it as, passing through the office. On the extortion calls, you can tell it's a well-oiled machine. It's methodical. They sound like they're negotiating the price of a car. They do this all the time.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
劳拉向她能想到的一切人寻求帮助。她去了当地警察局和市长办公室寻求帮助。他们联系了科里·布克参议员办公室，但大约一周后他们回复她时，已经太晚了。劳拉最终从她妈妈和妹妹那里筹集到了一些钱，但这只是绑架者要求的一小部分。
Laura turns to everyone she can think of. She goes to her local police department and to her mayor's office to ask for help. They reach out to the Office of Senator Cory Booker, but by the time they get back to her about a week later, it's too late. Laura eventually scrapes together money from her mom and sister, but just a fraction of what the cartel is asking for.
小伙子，我有1200美元……告诉我该怎么做，给我时间筹集更多。
Muchacho, yo te tengo 1,200 dollares...diceme que vamos a hacer y dame tiempo para conseguir otra parte más.
她告诉他们，看，我已经凑了1200美元。告诉我我们该怎么做，给我时间弄剩下的。那个男人说他会和老板商量。
She tells them, look, I've already pulled together $1,200. Tell me what we're going to do and give me time to get the rest. The man says he'll confer with his boss.
同时，他说，她应该汇钱。劳拉要求和大卫通话，他们让他接了。
In the meantime, he says, she should wire the money. Laura asks to talk to her brother and they put him on.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
她问大卫，哥哥，你好吗？他说很担心。她告诉他，别担心，她已经凑了一些钱。第二天，贩毒集团释放了大卫和他的儿子。在大卫获释三天后，我在电话里和他交谈。他非常痛苦，很难完整说出一句话。
She asks David, how are you, brother? Worried, he says. She tells him, don't worry, that she's pulled together some money. The next day, the cartel's released David and his son. I talk to David on the phone three days after his release. He's so distressed, it's hard for him to finish a sentence.
[啜泣]
[SOBBING]
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
“呼吸”，我告诉他。我想帮他。那不是记者应该说的话，但在他们被绑架时，他们的生命处于直接危险之中，我以微小的方式提供了帮助。
Breathe, I tell him. I wanted to help him. That's not something a reporter is supposed to say, but back when they were kidnapped, their lives were in immediate danger, and I helped in small ways.
我将劳拉与墨西哥城的一个为移民倡导的非政府组织联系起来。自从大卫和儿子获释后，我建议了安全的巴士选项。这家人一直都知道我是一个写关于他们的故事的记者，但他们开始视我为他们可以信任的极少数人之一——他们可以依赖的人。劳拉几乎每天都打电话给我更新情况。她现在仍然这样。
I connected Laura with an NGO in Mexico City that advocates for migrants. Since David and his son were released, I've suggested safe bus options. The family, they always knew that I was a reporter doing a story on them, but they came to see me as one of the few people they could trust-- that they could rely on. Laura called me almost every day with updates. She still does.
几周前，我去了墨西哥北部的蒙特雷见大卫和他的家人，他们躲在那里。他们住在劳拉认识的人家里，用杂货钱换取食宿，并帮助施工。大卫不想我们在那里采访他。他觉得他的欢迎已经用完了，所以我们在酒店做了采访。
A few weeks ago, I went to meet David and his family in Monterrey in northern Mexico, where they were holed up. They were staying with an acquaintance of Laura's in exchange for grocery money and help with construction. David didn't want us interviewing him there. He feels his welcome has run out, so we do the interview at our hotel.
是大卫，他11岁的儿子，和他19岁的女儿，她也是根据MPP被遣返回墨西哥的。我和我的制片人莉娜在那里。我们想我们会让孩子在另一个房间看电视，而我们在一个房间和大卫谈话，但孩子坐在床上爸爸身边。他们一步也不离开对方。
It's David, his 11-year-old son, and his 19-year-old daughter, who's also been sent back to Mexico under MPP. I'm here with my producer, Lina. We figure we'll talk to David in one room while the kids watch TV in the other, but the kids sit by their dad on the bed. They won't leave one another's side.
我想知道那天我在桥上离开他时发生了什么，他描述了所有这些贩毒集团绑架生意如何在内部运作的细节——那些常规的、而且非常可怕的细节。这就是发生的事情。
I wanted to know what happened when I left him that day on the bridge, and what he described were all these details of how the cartel's kidnapping business actually works once you're a victim on the inside-- details that were routine, and also terrifying. So here's what happened.
他说，那天被遣返回墨西哥的另外100个人和他一起从桥上被带到当地移民局进行处理。在那之后，他说一个穿着墨西哥移民官制服的男人同意带他和儿子去车站，这样他们就能去一个更安全的城市。但他们一到车站，他就有一种不祥的预感。
He said, he and the other 100 people who were sent back to Mexico that day were taken from the bridge to the local immigration office for processing. After that, he says a man wearing a Mexican immigration officer uniform agreed to take him and his son to the bus station so they could go to a safer city. But as soon as they got to the station, he got a bad feeling.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
当我带着儿子进去时，这个家伙抓住了我。他是个高个子，强壮，满身纹身。他抓住了我，说：我想和你谈谈。我说：我没什么和你谈的。
When I went in with my son, this guy grabbed me. He was a tall guy, strong, full of tattoos. So he grabbed me and he said, I want to talk to you. And I said, I have nothing to talk to you about.
他说：你要上那辆车，我们要问你一些问题。我说：不。他说：你可以选择简单的方式或者困难的方式上车。
And he said, you're going to get into that car, and we're going to ask you some questions. And I said, no. And he said, you can get into the car the easy way or the hard way.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
他说那天晚上至少还有十二个移民到达车站，贩毒集团把他们挤进不同的卡车。他说，所有的卡车都是崭新的。他记得他上的那辆是灰色的日产汽车，里面还有四五个移民。
He says at least a dozen migrants also arrived at the bus station that night, and the cartel hustled them into different trucks. All the trucks were brand new, he says. He remembers that the one he got into was a gray Nissan, and there were four or five other migrants in there with him.
他说，开车带他去车站的那个移民官员坐在车里，看着他们被送走。我们无法证实这一点，但执法机构与贩毒集团携手合作由来已久。例如，2011年，墨西哥移民局的七名高级官员在有关该机构参与绑架移民的指控中被解雇。
He says, the immigration officer who drove him to the bus station sat in his car and watched them all being carted off. We can't confirm this, but there is a long history of law enforcement and the cartels working hand-in-hand. For example, in 2011, seven top officials at Mexico's immigration agency were fired amid allegations that the agency was involved in the kidnapping of migrants.
这与他在新泽西州的妹妹告诉我的情况一致。她给那个移民官员汇钱买大卫的票，当她接到赎金电话时，绑架者让她把钱汇到同一个账户，就是移民官员用的那个。她说：那不是移民官员的账户吗？然后他们挂断了。
And it squares with what his sister in New Jersey told me. She wired money to that immigration officer for David's bus ticket, and when she got the ransom call, the kidnappers told her to wire the money to that same account, the one the immigration officer used. She said something like, isn't that the immigration officer's account? And they hung up.
我让墨西哥移民机构做出回应。他们告诉我，他们不知道最近有关于移民官员将移民交给贩毒集团的投诉。
I asked the Mexican immigration agency to respond. They told me they have no knowledge of recent complaints of immigration officers turning migrants over to the cartels.
在卡车里，大卫紧紧抱着儿子。绑架者没有说话。
In the truck, David held onto his son. The kidnappers didn't speak.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
那家伙只是叫我们低头，别再看风景了。开车的那个人一直在盯着我们，确保我们没有闲聊。他们把车窗全部摇上了。
The guy just told us to keep our heads down, to stop looking at the sights. And the guy who was driving us was keeping an eye on us, and he was making sure we were not chatting. They had the windows all rolled up.
卡车兜了一圈，但大卫怀疑他们只是在绕圈子，并没有走远。他们开到了一栋看起来很正常的房子前，有一个大门。
The truck drove around for a while, but David suspects they were just going in circles, but they didn't actually travel very far. They pulled up to a normal-looking house with a big gate.
在里面，绑架者用手机拍了大卫、他儿子和其他人的照片。他们审问大卫他是哪里人、职业、他是怎么到美国的，最重要的，他在美国有什么家人。这就像健康诊所的病人挂号，只是由贩毒集团进行的。
Inside, the kidnappers used their cell phones to take pictures of David, his son, and the rest. They interrogated David about where he's from, his line of work, how he got to the US, and most importantly, what family members he has there. It was like patient intake at a health clinic, except for by a cartel.
我们把贩毒集团称为有组织犯罪，但我从未想象过那种簿记。他们保留着绑架移民的记录和照片，以及谁被释放。
We talk about the cartels as organized crime, but I never imagined the bookkeeping. They keep records and photos of the migrants they kidnap, and also who they release.
大卫说屋子里有超过20名移民。男人和女人睡在不同的房间。白天，绑架者殴打任何试图看女人的男人。
David says there were more than 20 migrants at the house. The men and women slept in separate rooms. During the day, the kidnappers hit any of the men who tried to look at the women.
大卫和儿子睡的房间里有一张床垫。其他人睡在地板上。晚上，大卫会躺在地上，抱着他的儿子。
The room David and his son slept in had one mattress. Everyone else slept on the floor. At night, David would lay on the ground, holding his son.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我会和他躺在一个角落里，拥抱我的儿子。他们看不见你在哭，但我的眼泪几乎要掉下来了。
I would lay down with him in a corner, and I would hug my son. They couldn't see you crying, but my tears were almost, like, falling out.
艾米丽，最让我心痛的是，当那个家伙到来时，老板，他总是告诉我，我儿子的器官可以卖钱，他正值好年龄，他只有11岁。
What hurt me the most, Emily, was that when this guy arrived, the boss, he would always tell me that my son's organs were good for selling, that he was in a good age, that he was only 11 years old.
[西班牙语][哭泣]
[SPEAKING SPANISH] [CRYING]
我的儿子曾经听到那个家伙说他的肾脏——他的器官——很好卖，他几乎在哭。我告诉他，别哭，但我绝望了。
And my son once heard the guy saying that his kidneys-- that his organs-- were good for selling, and he was almost crying. And I told him, don't cry, but I was desperate.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
当大卫讲这个故事时，他的两个孩子仍然坐在他身边的床上。他们谁也没在看什么特别的东西。他们只是呆呆地坐着。
As David tells me this story, his two kids are still sitting on the bed beside him. Neither of them is looking at anything in particular. They're just sitting there blankly.
大卫似乎也失去了情感。他根本不像几周前获释后我谈话的那个大卫。现在，他的神情完全平淡。
David also seems devoid of emotion. He doesn't at all resemble the David from a few weeks ago, the one I talked to right after his release. Now, his affect is completely flat.
在绑架的第四天，老板之一叫醒了大卫，告诉他他们已经和他的妹妹达成了协议。
On the fourth day of his kidnapping, one of the bosses woke David up and told him they'd reached a deal with his sister.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
他对我说：带着你儿子起来，胖子，因为今天我要放你们走，因为你妹妹已经付了款，存了钱。
And he said to me, get up with your son, fat guy, because today I'm going to release you guys because your sister already paid, made a deposit.
那个男人告诉大卫，如果他告诉任何人——警察、记者——贩毒集团就会来找他，带走他儿子，并杀了他。最初绑架他们的那个人开车把他们送回车站，并给每人买了一张票。
The man told David if he talked to anyone-- police, reporters-- the cartel would come for him, take his son, and kill David. The same man who kidnapped them in the first place drove them back to the bus station and bought them each a ticket.
大卫不知道屋子里其他几十个人发生了什么。大多数被绑架后获释的移民，贩毒集团会给他们一个关键词。这就像一个通行码，表明移民已经还清了贩毒集团的债，所以不会再被绑架，但大卫没有得到，可能是因为他付的赎金不够高。
David doesn't know what happened to the dozens of other people in the house. Most migrants who are kidnapped and released, the cartel gives them a key word. It's like a passcode that indicates the migrant has paid off the cartel so they aren't kidnapped again, but David isn't given one, maybe because he hasn't paid a high enough ransom.
当我们在蒙特雷见到大卫时，他不知道该怎么办。在绑架的第一天，贩毒集团拿走了大卫和他儿子的移民文件，没有还给他们。没有那些文件，他甚至不知道自己应该在哪一天出庭。
When we met David in Monterrey, he didn't know what he was going to do. On day one of the kidnapping, the cartel had taken David and his son's immigration paperwork, and they didn't give it back. Without that paperwork, he doesn't even know which day he's supposed to show up in court.
但即使他能弄清楚，他也告诉我们，他太害怕回到新拉雷多。根据MPP，他必须经过同一个入境口岸才能参加听证会。如果我们再被绑架怎么办？他问。
But even if he could figure it out, he told us, he's too scared to return to Nuevo Laredo. Under MPP, he'd have to pass through the same port of entry to get to his hearing. What if we get kidnapped again? He asks.
上周，我接到了大卫的电话。他们一直待在蒙特雷的那家人想让他们离开，他已经对庇护程序失去了希望。他认为他们不会被倾听，听证程序是个谎言。
Last week, I got a phone call from David. The family they've been staying with in Monterrey wants them gone, and he's lost hope in the asylum process. He thinks they won't be listened to, that the hearing process is a lie.
事实上，关于他的案子可能的结果，他是对的。在本届政府下，基于帮派暴力获得庇护几乎是不可能的。所以大卫决定带家人回洪都拉斯，那个他们试图逃离的国家。根据国土安全部自己的统计，成千上万的其他家庭也正在做出同样的决定。
And in fact, he's right about how his case is likely to come out. Under this administration, it's virtually impossible to gain asylum based on gang violence. So David's decided to take his family back to Honduras, the country they tried escaping in the first place. According to Homeland Security's own statistics, thousands of other families are making the same choice.
艾米丽·格林。她也为Vice.com报道了大卫的事。在结束今天的节目之前还有最后一件事。当我们在马塔莫罗斯的帐篷营地时，我了解了“留在墨西哥”政策的运作方式。
Emily Green. She also reported on David for Vice.com. One last thing before we end today's program. When we were in the tent camp in Matamoros, I learned that the way the Remain in Mexico policy works.
它适用于成年人。但如果一个孩子没有大人陪同出现，边境特工必须让他们进入美国。他们不会把他们送回去。
It applies to adults. But if a kid shows up without an adult, the border agents have to let them into the United States. They don't send them back.
帐篷营地的生活很艰苦，很无聊，有些孩子会说：我想走。把我单独送走。我们遇到了一位父亲，他的15岁孩子就这样做了。在这种情况下，他和他的儿子都同意这可能更好。
And life in the tent camp is hard and boring, and there are kids who are like, I want to go. Send me alone. We met a dad whose 15-year-old did that. In this case, he and his son both agreed it will probably be better.
无论如何，他们试图进入美国的整个原因都是为了他儿子的未来。他在休斯顿有个姨妈。他会被送进另一边的收容所，但希望他能找到她。
The whole reason they were trying to get into the US was for his son's future, anyway. He has an aunt in Houston. He'd be put into a shelter on the other side, but hopefully he'd get to her.
这是一个赌博，但经过计算。所以几周前下午5:30，父亲带着他的青少年儿子走到边境站，拥抱了他，祈求上帝保佑他，然后送走了他。
It's was a gamble, but a calculated one. So at 5:30 in the afternoon a couple weeks ago, his father walked his teenager to the border station, gave him a hug, asked God to bless him, and sent him off.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
他只是，他对我说的唯一的话是：回头见，爸爸。
He just, the only thing he said to me is, I'll see you later, dad.
从那以后的两周里，他的儿子给母亲打了三次电话。她和他们的其他孩子在老家。父亲请求我不要具体说明是哪个国家，也不要说出他们的名字。
In the two weeks since then, his son has called his mother three times. She's back in their home country with their other children. The dad asked me not to specify what country or say their names.
他儿子说他和其他孩子被拘留在一起，并说这比帐篷营地好多了。换句话说，目前为止一切顺利。
His son said he's in custody with other kids, and says it's way better than the tent camp. In other words, so far so good.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
他在那里做得很好，他们对待他很好，他在那里得到了他需要的一切，他有睡觉的地方、食物、衣服，而且他还在上课。
He's doing well there, that they treat him well, that he gets everything he needs there, that he gets a place to sleep, food, clothing, and he also is getting classes.
现在唯一糟糕的部分是，父亲独自在这里。他想念他的儿子。他一直都在想他，他说，早上醒来第一件事，晚上睡觉前最后一件事。
The only bad part of it, now, is that the dad's here alone. He misses his son. He thinks about him all the time, first thing in the morning, he said, and last thing at night.
达尔文，那个营地的九岁国王——还记得他吗？他和妈妈告诉阿维娃，他们讨论过她是否应该让他单独过去自生自灭。
Darwin, that 9-year-old who's the king of the camp-- remember him? He and his mom told Aviva that they've talked about whether she should send him over alone to fend for himself.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
她问他，看，作为妈妈并不是我不爱他，但如果没有办法让他们一起走，她会让他单独走。但他不想那样。
She asked him, look, as a mom it's not that she doesn't love him, but if there's no way for them to go together, she'll send him alone. But he doesn't want that.
不。[西班牙语]
No. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
不，因为我有恐惧。
No, because of the fear that I have.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
老实说，你不会失去我的，她说。
Honestly, you won't lose me, she says.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我害怕我会失去我的妈妈。那里的孩子看不到他们的妈妈。
My fear is that I'll lose my mom. The kids there don't see their moms.
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我从未和她分开过，他说。她插话说，我们的爱是不可分割的。他坐在她的脚边，搂住她的腿。她把胳膊搂住他。
I've never been separated from her, he says. And she jumps in, our love is inseparable. He's sitting at her feet and hugs her legs. She puts her arm around him.
所以如果你的妈妈告诉你你应该独自进入美国，你会告诉她什么？
So if your mom tells you you should cross into the US by yourself, what would you tell her?
[西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我尝试过了，她说，但他不想去。他拒绝了，开始哭。她也不想让他走，但鉴于事情可能会如何发展，她不确定还能做什么。
I tried it, she says, and he doesn't want to go. He refuses and starts to cry. And she doesn't want him to go, but given how things might play out, she's not sure what else to do.
嗯，我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼制作，阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德提供帮助。制作今天节目的人包括埃尔纳·贝克、埃曼纽尔·贝里、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、杰西卡·卢森霍普、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、本·费伦、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。
Well, our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman with help from Aviva Dekornfeld. The people who put together today's show includes Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
我们的执行主编是戴安·吴。我们的执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天节目的翻译是加布里埃拉·穆尼奥斯、卡塔琳娜·玛丽亚·约翰逊、丹尼尔·谢尔和马里奥·米切莱纳。我们在马塔莫罗斯的中间人是记者维罗·卡德纳斯。节目中第一个故事里的庇护官员的声音是由玛吉·西夫和贝蒂·吉尔平表演的。
Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Interpreters for today's show where Gabriela Muñoz, Catalina Maria Johnson, Daniel Sherr, and Mario Michelena. Our fixer in Matamoros was journalist Vero Cardenas. The voices of the asylum officers in the first story of the show were performed by Maggie Siff and Betty Gilpin.
顺便提一下，你可以在《亿万》里看到玛吉·西夫，在Netflix的《美女摔角联盟》里看到贝蒂·吉尔平。今天特别感谢哈里森·内斯比特和艾米·考夫曼、金布雷尔·凯利、雷纳尔多·利亚诺斯二世、肯吉·基祖卡、克里斯托弗·特平、威廉·多布森、迪德里克·尚什、拉塞尔·迪翁·刘易斯、克莱·博格斯、莫琳·迈耶、尼克·米里洛和伍德森·马丁。
By the way, you can see Maggie Siff on Billions and Betty Gilpin on the Netflix show Glow. Special thanks today to Harrison Nesbit and Amy Kaufman, Kimbrell Kelly, Reynaldo Leanos Jr., Kennji Kizuka, Christopher Turpin, William Dobson, Didrik Schanche, Russell Dion. Lewis, Clay Boggs, Maureen Meyer, Nick Miriello, and Woodson Martin.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他最近给一些讨厌洋葱和任何葱属植物的朋友做了晚饭。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he recently cooked dinner for some friends who hate onions and anything in the onion family.
而且他们想把泄密控制在最低限度。
And they wanted to keep the leak to a minimum.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。